I'm just gonna get serious for one
moment and talk about an issue that I
think is a near and dear to all of our
hearts and particularly mine you know
that old police say that comic-con is
only for nerdy white guys you know that
gets more outdated every year yeah and
and the people I'm just getting started
here the people who create pop culture
have taken notice too especially with
their inclusion of more african-american
characters whether whether it does he
beats and Deadpool or chadwick boseman
is the Black Panther young black fans
seeing themselves reflected in these
heroes is a very powerful thing and as
as these movies become part of our
collective cultural mythology I believe
listen to Slenderman up there acting
like he's so down with diversity of
black empowerment man Conan is so out of
touch he thinks woek is the past tense
of wookie he thinks Malcolm X is the
sequel to Malcolm's 1 through 9
Conan so white his blood type is Miracle
Whip he thinks could be and Michael B
Jordan stands for basketball I know
exactly what you mean
[Applause]
listen to this mini white checker shoot
off at the mouth but far too long and
really what does Conan know about
diversity in comic books he once asked
me if the black widows husband was also
black the closest he's ever been to
Africa was orchestra seats for the Lion
King he's so right the only time he ever
mentions Wakanda is when he asked the
waiter what kind of white wine pairs
best with his bottle and how can you
hear my thoughts and how can I hear
yours don't you know all black people
can communicate by telephone hey why
don't we get a drink after the show and
you can use those claws ticky Conan's
Falvo it would be my pleasure
what kind of forever
is so vital thank you very much
you